but first up is a longtime confidence of
our current president and now author of
the making of the president 2016 how
Donald Trump orchestrated a revolution
Donald Trump's albino assassin Roger
stone Roger
[Music]
now you don't mind that I call you his
albino assassin do you know comrade me
bill okay well let's let's start with
that because we've known each other a
long time I know you'll be straight with
me
it looks like Donald Trump and his crime
family wherein were installed by Russia
to loot and destroy America as a
longtime Republican lifelong Republican
who cut his teeth working for Richard
Nixon quite a cold warrior yes give you
any sort of unease that were so in touch
with the evil empire these days well not
really if you looked at the Obama
Clinton policies the reset they rolled
into Crimea Crimea Syria we didn't stop
them we continued selling them
transferring technology to them so they
really rolled over the last
administration I think is what it boils
down to bill and that is do we want to
go to war over Syria that's what this is
about
I know there's no not about cereal is
about our election so it's about America
not Syria right no no not about Syria
not America it's about it's about okay
it's about it's not the Neo bronze who
gave us war the bushes and the Clintons
and the chances that you could negotiate
a peace before welding a proxy war
Nigeria I know that your favorite
musician must be Muddy Waters because
Billy that is what you always do I just
want to give peace a chance is muddy
waters but that is nothing but it's a
thing you mentioned war because both
Dick Cheney not exactly a liberal and
John McCain same thing have said this
hacking of our election would be
considered an act of war if we had some
evidence or proof of it right now we had
interesting we have is is inference okay
okay so Senator Mark Warner who's head
of the Intelligence Committee in the
Senate okay he the first thing out of
his mouth the other day when he was
asked about this he said there's clearly
a lot of smoke and then he said an
individual that would be me
that's you he said associated with the
Trump campaign accurately predicted the
release of hacked emails before it
happened the same individual you also
admits to being in contact with gusoff
ur 2.0 who all of our intelligence
agency says guseva 2.0 is Russian
military intelligence yeah I just boot
that take them one by one first of all I
have never said that I had advanced
knowledge of the hacking of Podesta's
emails
there's no quote for me is that his time
in the barrel right and there's been
there's been over a hundred stories
written from that time to Election Day
about his business dealings in Russia
Bank deals gas deals and others that's
what I was referring to including a long
piece I wrote myself on October 30 okay
but but goose with this gusoff ur the
inference that Lucifer that my twitter
exchange with Lucifer Carleton so that's
what a direct mail no direct mail within
the Twitter sister okay but it was not
supposed to be public but it is public
because I really do chose to make it I
released it all no one else released it
I released I don't think that's true
that is absolutely I think he released
it after it became I released it after
became no it became known it existed
which could only be known okay
no no it could only be known if my if my
Twitter feed had been hacked okay so and
I released it it's benign it's inoculate
okay but but but here's what goobers are
good engages in espionage would you
really do it on Twitter uh you're really
asking that with Trump in the White
House okay but but here's what he did
get them here's what here's what guseva
is that about you apparently you in here
big fan G said I'm pleased to say Roger
stone you are a great man so what he's
Romanian why are you saying that in a
Russian accent we tell me if I can help
you anyhow
I would be great pleasure to me and then
he said same days at Rogers phone paying
you back that's very simple because he's
referring at the top of that email
exchange to an article I wrote on August
5th at Breitbart in which I argued that
he is the one who hacked the DNC you
know he was a hero I think he is a hero
I'm opposed to the deep state I think
they need to be exposed but true or
false let's you know let's play truth or
dare dare now and we're not going to
dare each other okay you really think as
a lot of Republicans do that the
Democrats are more of an existential
threat to America than Russia no I
wouldn't say that at all lying but but I
am disappointed I think I think you do
and I think anything it takes to keep
the Democrat side apart I think you
actually believe that well I'd like to
see a democratic party's would stand up
to Islamic terrorism that would protect
a people that would protect Christians
that would protect women right they
don't seem to be inclined to do that all
right well let's not get to a place
where we agree all right so here's Trump
was asked on February 16th can you say
whether you are aware that anyone who
advised your campaign had contacts with
Russia and he said no nobody that I know
of nobody so he doesn't know you know
but I didn't know his son-in-law and I
know he doesn't know his hold on and he
does any no any inference that my
communications with a groups were 2.0
constitutes collusion is been ruled by
the convolution and the mess
illusion can you say whether you are
aware that anyone who advised your
campaign had contacts with Russia this
is proven it's now that all these people
had contacts we don't use I don't
conceive the goose fur is Russian but if
you go online you'll see there ok very
route this they met an ambassador kiss
lyac who is known as the top recruiter
of spies in this country you can't deny
that the contacts with Russia and he
said nobody that I know of this is just
a giant obvious lie he knows you he
knows men afford he knows his son-in-law
I think I've had no contacts with
Russians let's be very clear the New
York Times on January 20th says that
they have emails records of financial
transactions and then on the 30th they
add transcripts from telephone calls ok
where are they produce them let's see
them let's hear you but we have meetings
we have Michael Flint is right now
asking for immunity I don't was he had
contacts with Russia Trump knows Michael
Flynn so that's a lie let's talk about
Michael Flynn he says he has a story to
tell
tell me a story what what what is what
is the story let's talk about anything
his story I have no idea but here's what
I do know I'm not asking for immunity
I was maligned by a number of the
numbers of committee who said things
were patently false and in a free
society I should have a chance to
respond in the same forum open once and
for no one would and I don't want to
need a subpoena right
I don't need immunity but I wanted to be
in public not behind closed doors let's
go I'm ready we've had you on the show
from back in politically incorrect days
I don't want to see you in prison with
that Nixon tattoo on your back that's
you just have sex I'm the only guy you
know that dipped on the front and the
back
it's okay
parrot I'll give you that one all right
Donald Trump jr. said this Russians make
up a pretty disproportionate
cross-section of a lot of our assets and
then he said there's a lot of money
pouring in from Russia
his brother Eric Trump said we had no
assets in Russia we have no debt in
Russia I think we held a Miss Universe
in Russia like he doesn't know that okay
this is called not getting your story
straight which one of these two sons of
Donald Trump is lying because one says
Russians make up a pretty
disproportionate cross-section of our
assets and one says we had no assets in
Russia well you run for president you
have to file an extensive financial
disclosure why delighted to certify it
well he both candidates did that but
there were no resident my question we
never know is lying well it's a
privately held company so I don't know
but the financial disclosure that why
would vial with the government showed no
Russian asset but why if coucher says we
have a pretty dis portion of
cross-section of assets would you day
say we have no assets he also said we
don't have any properties in Russia
yeah Russia has properties here like the
White House okay so let's move on a guy
named Clinton watts he used to be with
the FBI said this week if you want to
get to the bottom of this follow the
trail of dead Russians and there have
been a lot of dead Russians lately
people who had knowledge since all this
came out about the hacking and so forth
now you don't really plan to sit there
and tell me Putin wasn't responsible a
guy was thrown out of a window that
doesn't happen just because he slipped
on the butter well have we had a way to
defense secretary Forrestal that
happened to so look what that's the
answer here is full disclosure let's let
the president order the release of all
documents pertaining to alleged
collusion with the Russian but you said
you you listen you never self were
poisoned
yes I think I was and you're on there
not on this side I'm a patriotic
American I forgot were you poisoned run
because I think a lot of people would
not like me to testify because I will
put the the lie to this Russian myth I
never had any contacts with the Russian
state to my knowledge no one else in the
campaign did I think perhaps the
Democrats could get over the fact that
they spent about two and a half billion
dollars Trump spent about two hundred
seventy eight million and they lost okay
but that's what this is really about it
well they're actually they won but yes
by the OU College they either soon as I
possible oh yes by the Platte River okay
but a guy you do talk to is Donald Trump
from time to time from time to time
okay you know what Donald Trump says I'm
hearing I'm hearing that's you you think
I think it is I don't think I mean you
have been on this guy side since 1988
you nobody puts words in Donald Trump's
mouth no but they put thoughts in his
cotton head well and it's not that hard
to do he just won a historic election
for some reason and the reason is not
well Rutter in collusion certainly that
was a that was in the Knicks we found
out this week that 8,000 Russian trolls
were putting fake news stories about
Hillary Clinton out there who told us
that the CIA the guys who talks about
weapons of mass destruction or Benghazi
or rendition or or torture Abu Dhabi
prison their track record on honesty not
too good bill okay well some of that is
not about honesty that the you're
talking about the Iraq war okay a lot of
the people in the CIA disagreed with the
findings of the director okay that's
happening today too
okay so you're saying that that's not
true let me ask you more general
questions you've been in Donald Trump's
corner for a long time yes you've seen
out of it president for for 70 or so
days any buyer's remorse
anything that gives you pause
you know for the first year of his
presidency first two years the courts
and the Congress thwarted everything
Franklin Roosevelt wanted to do you
can't judge the Trump presidency on a
couple months okay I think his voters
want to see him to continue to fight for
the things he said that he would fight
for it's not that the travel ban gets
knocked down it's that he keeps trying
to pass it it's Dave Allen once said
that we're in the trouble we are in
because of a the 60s culture of
narcissism no we're in trouble we're in
the trouble racism is that an issue I
don't I don't think that's the reason
we're the trouble we're the trouble
we're a issue with Donald Trump and
narcissism I don't think that's the
overriding national problem we're in the
trouble that we're in because the Bush
Clinton Bush Obama continued on the
neocon continuum has gotten us endless
war or an erosion of our civil liberties
our massive debt and spending spying on
us as a foreign policy that's incoherent
alright let's end on a positive note I
there's an issue we agree on another one
marijuana you think Jeff Sessions is
wrong completely wrong to be such a
hard-ass on marijuana is that because
you yourself are a Roger stoner only
when I'm in the states where it's legal
okay
well this happens to be on of them we
looked at our log this is our four
hundred and twentieth show yes so we
have a cake coming out later would you
do the really honor of bringing out the
4/20 cake I would be happy to the
candidate Trump said that he should let
the state's decide he was absolutely
right he needs to turn back in my word
great to see you Thank You Roger stone I
wish you good luck with your testimony
I just don't everybody likes there he
goes kids are fast
[Music]